los primeros cuidados después del horror
de la guerra esta habitante de mariupol
logró escapar de la ciudad sitiada y
ahora está en manos del personal médico
de este hospital de sap orilla al huir
lo dejó todo atrás y
no se es en mi casa sigue en pie si
ardió o si sigue allí no hay forma de
comunicarse es imposible establecer
contacto telefónico hemos abandonar la
ciudad arriesgando la vida buscando
refugio este hombre perdió una pierna y
nos detuvimos una bala impactó contra mi
ventana y al salir del auto pisé una
mina
vivíamos una vida normal no pedimos
sufrir todo esto no queríamos de que
libertad habla putin por su culpa perdí
mi pierna
el 90% de mariupol está destruida según
las autoridades de la ciudad algunas
personas no tienen a donde ir y viven al
día sin suministro de agua estos
habitantes hacen fila para conseguir
agua potable no muy lejos estos obreros
limpian los escombros de un edificio
bombardeado
con miedo a encontrar nuevos cuerpos
entre las ruinas ante el parlamento
surcoreano el presidente de lenski
estimó que decenas de miles de personas
habrían muerto en la ciudad portuaria y
pidió mayor intervención occidental de
malla en emoción útil no cabe la
posibilidad de que rusia se detenga por
sí misma
no hay ninguna posibilidad de que entre
en razón y los dirigentes rusos rechacen
continuar con esta guerra
sólo se puede obligar a rusia a
detenerse
entre este campo de escombros en el que
se ha convertido mariupol se prepara una
última batalla según el ejército de kiev
un asalto final de las tropas rusas
frente a soldados ucranianos desvalidos
y escasos de municiones sin capacidad
para aguantar mucho más el sitio